[Music]
style and rail doors can have one or
more panels even sectioned glass panels
like crown molding they come in a wide
selection of profiles
if they're making a paint grade door
they use poplar if the door surface will
be stained they use a wood species the
customer ordered the many choices range
from oak and cherry to maple and african
mahogany
they feed the rough lumber through a
planer that has three stations
the first two successively shaved the
top and bottom to reduce the piece to
the required thickness
the third station has multiple saw
blades which cut the piece into several
strips
workers line up those strips side by
side and coat one side with glue
then they transfer the wood strips to
the table of a clamping machine
repeatedly sandwiching one piece of
linear strand lumber in between the
glued sides of two solid wood strips
linear strand lumber lsl for short is a
piece of lumber made from glued wood
fibers
a robot clamps the strips tightly to the
lsl core
this assembly stays clamped on the
machine for an hour for the glue to dry
then they put this engineered lumber
through a glue spreader to coat the top
and bottom surfaces with heat activated
glue
they sandwiched the lumber between two
paper thin sheets of wood known as
veneer
for a paint grade door instead of wood
veneer they use ultra thin mdf
medium density fiberboard a man-made
material with a smooth paint-friendly
surface
they place the pieces into a hot press
for two minutes
the heat activates the glue while the
pressure flattens the veneer against the
lumber forming a cohesive unit
these pieces will become the doors
styles and rails
to produce the panel inside those styles
and rails workers contour a piece of mdf
with a shaper machine
for a stained door workers veneer the
mdf beforehand
they interchange the head on the machine
to cut different profiles
now back to those engineered wood pieces
for the styles and rails
with a different shaper machine workers
have profiled the inside edge of the
styles
they've also drilled holes to receive
the dowels of the adjoining rails
after applying glue they attach the
similarly profiled bottom rail to the
first style
they insert the panel into a groove in
the rail and style
this is a two panel door so they fit a
middle rail
another panel
a top rail then the second style
they place the now assembled door in the
same type of clamping machine as before
only larger
it applies pressure on the door for an
hour while the glue dries
workers then transfer the machine to a
cutting table where a computer-guided
saw trims the top and bottom of the door
the machine then switches to a different
tool and bevels the edge of the door
it switches tools again and machines
holes for the door hardware
the style and rail door is now ready for
finishing
workers sand the surface to prepare it
to receive wood stain
or if it's a paint grade door primer
workers apply the stain or primer
manually with a spray gun
the stained doors then receive a coat of
sealer and two coats of clear lacquer to
protect the wood surface
the panels in style and rail doors are
never glued in place
they sit inside the frame this leaves
space for the wood and mdf to naturally
expand with seasonal humidity without
warping or cracking the door